why,
hello, gustavo, thank you for coming and taking
the time to answer these 21
questions
[Applause]
what is there are some that today normally I
don't have much time for breakfast the
truth is that my days start to
end very, very late and it's not like
that I had breakfast
but today I had
a smoothie a quite nutritious strawberry smoothie
normally as you come to
school as you travel here to your
work
my house created
an hour and a half
at the workplace and well I have to
take my car to be able to  arrive although
what is your mind set when you enter the
school what do you feel you have well
then there may be currently we
are not taking face-to-face classes
all our classes are being in
virtual mode but the mainz in either the
face-to-face part or the virtual part
is always that  I am going to do today
to transform the lives of my students
and that they in turn can transform
their environment their community tell me one
thing you love about it  to the area where
this space is total these spaces that are
incredible have been the means of the
greatest successes we have made in
our school who is a doctor or actress right
now in movies
I love julia roberts she is one of my
favorite actresses especially because of the
type of  personality of empowerment
to women
who is your favorite artist or band
my favorite artist well it could be my
favorite band of the rider who is your
hero
but well if we talk about him
the fictional part batman I loved
batman and especially for this theme of  the
vulnerability that he recognizes his fear
and from his fear he recognizes his
strength I love it and in the
real part of the real world I have, well,
several, almost all of them women I am
very, very committed to the whole issue
training girls and women
on  all in the areas of science and
technology and one of them is rhythm the
creator and founder of claire her coach
tell me a place you would love to visit  tar
I would love to visit
a place that I could not visit this year
that I had the opportunity that it is the place
where Legos were created I think this
is like the mecca of creativity what
was your favorite subject in
school mathematics definitely
and the least favorite  favorite of all
those subjects that had to do
with creativity what kind of student was a
student
of what constantly challenged the
rules that you now fear from your work
when normally and beautifully we are in
the virtual field but normally
when it is witnessed even now  my
activity and that you generally continue
working when you get home if
normally yes, that is, this is my day
here it ends but well the projects that
I have in other organizations or these
social impact projects just for the one
that I am preparing right now
we are going to send to the  students and
after these students they are going to design this type
of activities for children in situations
because m  more vulnerable because these
projects require work to
continue after the usual day
and what do you do to relax afterwards I
really like to read I really like to go for a
run for a walk I take my dogs out for a walk I
listen to music I like
listening to music practically that
which ones  it's your hobbies or your passions
outside the area of teaching I rea
ly like diocesan dancing it's something that
ot everyone knows and in fact it su
denly generates a little contr
st not because there's personality norma
ly because it's more like an intro
ert it's more like  in the
electoral part or the part is programming
but when people know how I
like to dance and all kinds of music it's
like it's nice
what is the achievement that you feel most
proud of as a
teacher being able to think about things all the time
in which they can play with the
aim of giving the same number of
opportunities to all my students
those same opportunities that I
had  I would have liked to have had as a boy
and I had the fortune then to be
able to see that one of my students about
my female students comes to my class thinking
that he is not creative or that he is not going to be
given the technological part and that he has that
possibility of  discovering these
skills and these talents for me is
the maximum dow if you could write a
motivational phrase on a blackboard what
would
it be because it is right in this phrase
what is one of the women
we teach girls to be
brave and not perfect that is something  that
I have tried to make them
understand all this time that these
spaces and these
learning experiences must be a safe space
for them to try to prove
that they are wrong and that from that
experiment to discover their talents
and put them at the service point
What is the most important advice that you would
give or that you give to your students?
I think that is exactly what we are going to say that the
school should be that space where
they can  they give their talents a try they can
use their talents so that they are
happy and in a next step put them
at the service of society so that it
transforms the world
last question why did you become a
teacher
I became the teacher that
I always wanted to have for myself and all
practices  what I do every day all
the effort I put into innovating in
doing things in a different way
which is because I believe that in front of me
every day I have the people who
can change the world thank you